um I wanted to start with a little bit
about where kubernetes started and where
it is today right and I think that one
of the things that it started with
actually was deployment and continuous
delivery and what really motivated me
when we were starting out a long time
ago at this point was the fact that I
was trying to put together these
reliable deployments
and they worked and we were using you
know the sort of devops tools at the
time a mixture of puppet and Chef and
salt and ansible and you know bash
obviously
um and it worked I would say about 85
percent of the time
and then you'd sort of massage it and
everything else and it eventually would
work maybe 95 of the time
um and so kubernetes started effectively
out of this idea of deployment and the
fact that it was too hard too unreliable
to get to a place where you could
actually deploy things successfully
um I think it was combined with a lot of
interesting things that Docker was doing
in the container revolution around
hermetically sealing and packaging up of
an application that is a necessary
prerequisite to thinking about how you
then deploy it and I think what's
amazing that's happened over the last
decade is that it's actually become the
way that we do things it's moved from an
idea that I might be talking about here
to something that is just the way that
it works and it's just the expected way
that it works and admittedly you know
everybody's sort of had different
varying stages of their evolution
towards containers but I don't think
that it's something that you know I need
to go on and length about about why you
should be we should be doing that and I
think what's nice now is that we're
actually with things like get Ops
they're starting to actually take
another a crack at the process of
deployment not just or excuse me the
thing that leads into the deployment
that kubernetes orchestrates effectively
how do I get my configurations from
Source control all the way through and
out into uh into the world
into a place where kubernetes can do
something with it um so I'm going to
step through a little bit about what was
motivating us at the time and then
hopefully we'll tie that back to what I
think get Ops is doing today and why I
think it's an important piece of the
toolkit when we're talking about
reliable delivery one of the most
important things that we talked about
was declarative right and I think at
this point hopefully declarative
configuration is not something that is
uh controversial to anybody but honestly
at the time it was there was a lot of
scripting that happened out there there
was a lot of programs that ran to do
various things and honestly when you
look at sort of a CI CD pipeline it kind
of actually is a pretty imperative thing
at some times even if it's been
described in yaml it's a workflow
diagram that's effectively executing a
program and so I think you know the one
of the things that I think is nice about
some of the moves towards git Ops is it
really reinforces that declarative
nature of kubernetes from the get-go
another really important piece of what
we were thinking about at least what I
was thinking about was how do we empower
people to do more how do we you know
take away a bunch of the burdens that
they were having to deal with on the
day-to-day of you know whether it's
unreliability or uh you know just
thoughts that they had to figure out all
of the lists I mean in honesty all the
list of the things that a junior
software engineer needs to go through
that was referenced in the earlier talks
some of that is absolutely things that
you need to learn but a lot of it
hopefully we can take away with the
right kind of processes and the right
kind of sort of you know analysis of
what we what you know what is confusing
and what is hard for somebody to figure
out so that sort of sense of empowerment
is another important piece and I'll
hopefully tie that back to where good
Ops is coming from another really
interesting piece of this is automatic
right and I think that one of the one of
the analogies that I like to say is then
we talked about this at the time is that
kubernetes is sort of the autopilot for
your system and I think that the move
towards get Ops and the move towards
some of these models also helps things
be a little bit more automatic which in
turn makes it easier for everybody to
not really have to think about what
they're doing and simply have you know I
set a thermostat it doesn't really I
don't have to you know sort of
constantly be thinking like do I heat it
a little bit more do I cool it a little
bit more it just sort of takes care of
it in the background it takes what I
want to be present in the world and it
turns it into the reality that surrounds
me and then finally separation of
concerns and I think this is an
important piece of everything that we've
done really in devops in modern
distributed software development in
Agile development all of these pieces I
mean we're all been sort of like moving
around this idea that we're better off
if we separate our teams out into
relatively small groups relatively
focused on specific things and have
really clean lines of Separation so that
I can sort of know where my world stops
and where your world starts right
there's this great Robert Frost quote
that from one of his poems that good
fences make good neighbors and I think
it's really true in the systems that we
build it's very very helpful to have a
concrete understanding of sort of where
my zone of control is where someone
else's zone of control is and it's not
about like you know keeping people out
necessarily it's really about
understanding responsibility and the
ability to actually let go and say yeah
I'm going to care you know what happens
in my space but I may not care quite as
much about what happens in their space
as long as that divide underline that
contract that I have within their
neighboring services or with anyone else
as long as that contract is being is
being upheld and I'm going to start with
that into the into the real meat of what
we're talking about when we're talking
about githubs by branching into
something that was sort of referred to
earlier in the previous talk around the
fact that actually in modern software
development and in modern application
deployment there's a bunch of different
personas that are coming in right I
think this is not something that this is
something that I didn't really
appreciate honestly when I started in
the industry and even honestly at some
level when I started when we started
working on the kubernetes project
um even you're a developer you kind of
like I don't know I will say that you
take on a little bit of a mono-focused
view of the world that like I build
programs and I deploy programs and I
guess there's other stuff that happens
somewhere else
um but you know except for when they
bother me
I don't really think about it too much
um and as you talk more and more to
people who are building and deploying
software you actually realize that there
are a whole bunch of these personas that
come in and I've got three of them up
right here we talked uh the previous
talk talked a little bit about sort of
the security Persona that is responsible
for ensuring compliance is responsible
for ensuring
um you know Baseline security that
you're all using the same certificate
authorities if you're still using
certificates or you're still using the
same identity providers all of that
stuff is one of these personas that
comes in the platform Persona is one
that I think is becoming a more you know
thing that people are thinking about
over the last two three four years this
idea of platform engineering is
something that is becoming uh something
that people are talking about where you
know people have sort of said hey you
know kubernetes takes you to a certain
level it actually really doesn't help
you become a better developer of
distributed systems and for most of our
developers we're actually going to have
to put another layer on top call that a
platform and actually really have a team
that specializes in how do I build that
platform they're not really building
applications they're building sort of
the the framework that makes building
applications easier and then of course
obviously there's developer personas
many different teams deploying many
different applications now the challenge
of this is they all come together in the
same cluster
right I need to have intrusion detection
software I need to have monitoring and
observability I need to probably have
you know storage systems or other kinds
of platform level componentry where I
don't necessarily want every single
developer trying to decide which version
of a nosql database that they should be
deploying and then finally obviously I'm
going to have my application teams
there's a lot of problems that come out
of the fact that these multiple personas
have to mix together on this cluster
the first is that you know obviously if
you have to have people deploying into
these places you have to figure out
who's going to actually get access
am I going to let my security team have
control over every single cluster that
exists in my company that could be
hundreds to even thousands of clusters
in a large organization and it's
definitely a bit of a risk to have one
group or one identity one that has
access to all of that infrastructure
similarly if I'm a developer I don't
necessarily want to provide access to
the security team into that
infrastructure into my part of the
applications
because I don't want them messing around
and accidentally deleting the serving
application they don't really know the
truth is that you know they don't
necessarily they're very focused on what
they're doing they don't necessarily
know what's going on with my application
and similarly for platform engineering
we need to have a ubiquitous platform
all the way across for it to be
effective you need the same platform
across the company but you probably
don't want them mucking around with the
individual components on individual
clusters and vice versa security team
probably doesn't really want to have to
go to every single development team in
fact I know they don't because it's
increasingly painful to do this sort of
stuff they don't want when they need to
roll out a new version of intrusion
detection or they need to roll out a new
version of their own software for
logging monitoring and that sort of
thing they don't want to go to every
single development team and say hey by
the way we really need you to update and
here's the new version
that's a recipe for a lot of meetings a
lot of delays and you know in my
experience literally months of time
spent trying to roll out a new version
of a particular piece of software and so
I think git Ops really helps turn this
into something that's feasible and the
reason that it turns into something that
is feasible is because if you install
something for git Ops like in the Azure
kubernetes service we use flux although
Argo and there's other Solutions as well
there's great Solutions out there in the
um
in the cncf landscape if you install a
get op solution suddenly it's no longer
the case that each of these personas has
to manage a cluster
it's now the case that each of these
personas has to manage a git Repository
it's important to realize that actually
you have flipped your access control a
little bit
right I don't think we necessarily think
of version access to the you know
version control system as being access
control to a cluster
it is in the world of get Ops and so you
have to be definitely very careful
two-factor always a good idea definitely
a good idea in this context
um similarly using you know
true identity providers using the same
identity provider that you're using for
your documents and email and everything
else all of these things are important
considerations that may not be a part of
what went into your Source control
decision making
um but once you do that then you have
effectively partitioned out your cluster
so you can have a namespace that's
associated with the security team you
can have a namespace that's associated
with an application team you can have a
namespace or multiple namespaces that
are associated with platform teams they
each have individual access to the
individual repository that happens to
represent the state of the world for
that particular area of the cluster
um but actually if you go all the way to
the extreme effectively nobody has to
have standing access to do anything in
in the cluster because the get Ops
agentry that's running inside the
cluster itself
knows how to talk to that git repository
knows how to pull things down and make
it happen right so this separation of
concerns into and specifically taking
that one cluster and turning it into
multiple clusters connected to
repositories where the state of Truth is
stored means that there's a lot of power
for those multiple personas without
worrying too much about having them step
on each other's toes
I wanted to highlight another really
valuable piece of this that I think
um get Ops manages for for people
especially in the security context there
was a little bit of discussion in the
previous talk around you know software
security bill of materials all of this
sort of stuff this is an area that has
become increasingly important to people
over the last few years very much so
um and I wanted to really highlight that
one of the value propositions of git ops
isn't just the get to the cluster part
it's actually what you can do on the
repository side also
and again like this is stuff that is
possible with cicd you can set up
Jenkins and you can set up GitHub
actions and you can set up any number of
traditional pipeline systems to take the
output of a pull request merging into a
git repository turn it into reality on
your cluster
but I think there's just something about
the fact that it is so automatic in the
world of git Ops
um that makes it at least I've
personally found that it makes it
significantly more powerful so this up
here is an example of a PR this is
connected to my own home cluster
um where I happen to be running a uh
Prometheus and grafana to monitor some
you know internet of things things that
are happening in my house
um and honestly previous to using
dependabot which sent me this PR and git
Ops for managing the deployment I fell
way behind I was six months behind eight
months behind nine months behind these
sort of like
stuff that I wasn't really developing
right whether it's this sidecar which is
responsible for paying attention to and
downloading configuration maps to
configure Prometheus or whether it was
Prometheus itself
um it just didn't stay up to date just
because you had to sort of figure it out
and you had to do a manual change and
you had to merge pull requests and it's
just not that it was hard it's just
annoying
um and so this workflow
single-handedly transformed me from
being six to nine months out of date to
being less than a week out of date
because dependabot scans my repository
every night
figures out if there's new uh images
that are available for the various
components sends me a PR
and then you know once every couple days
if I'm bored if I'm backstage wherever
it happens to be I you know flick up
GitHub on my phone go through a bunch of
PR's merge merge merge merge merge and
then I forget about it
and in the background the get Ops agent
tree that's running on my cluster
connects to this repository sees the
change merges the PRC takes the new PR
deploys it to kubernetes new images pop
up
and I'm up to date right and so
literally the cognitive load of me
staying up to date in a in my own home
cluster is three minutes with my phone
backstage
so this workflow and again there's
nothing I'm again I don't want to be
like oh my gosh it's brand new because
you could have done this with cicd
certainly possible but for whatever
reason I found
um
you know because setting up a CI CD
system is its own sort of cognitive load
this inversion of like oh I can just
point it to get repo oh Dependable I can
merge PR's into that git repo has made
it ludicrously simple
um and effectively inexcusable for me to
not stay up to date
um and I just totally over talked that
slide so we'll move on
um I think the other piece that I think
we really see a bunch of value with in
the get Ops workflows is actually in
enabling that developer persona and this
is sort of where the platform engineer
and the developer intersect which is
that for a lot of developers they really
don't want to be thinking about uh the
specific details of how they get their
code deployed into kubernetes
they want to push whether it's Java or
python or net or rust or go or whatever
your favorite language is
they want to push some code get a
container image build out the other side
and then have that deployed immediately
right and again I think that the value
of the the git Ops thing here is that it
enables them to do this at scale
right it enables them to say like
actually you know you don't have to
necessarily worry about the fact that
there's five clusters in our
organization
you don't necessarily have to even be
really aware of where those clusters are
because when you switch from a poem or
excuse me from a push model of pipelines
to a pull model of get Ops
all of those clusters the number of
clusters that you have
stops mattering quite as much because
you're really only dealing with the git
repository if a new cluster comes into
existence or an old cluster goes away
you don't even actually necessarily as a
developer have to notice
the same workflows that push code to
four clusters will push code to five
clusters without any reconfiguration on
your part and so I think again that
world of moving being able to keep the
same basic workflows without any changes
without any modifications to my
repository even as I perhaps go from
early pre-prod to staging to production
in my application lifespan
um really reduces the cognitive load
that a developer has to put into
understanding where their code goes once
it deploys they can continue to focus on
that git repository as the sort of sole
source of Truth and then of course the
platform engineering team can really
focus on the initialization of that git
repository as being the act that
empowers their developer to to
effectively forget about that stuff
I wanted to riff off of that same idea
to talk about snowflakes
um it's possible that this whole idea of
a snowflake has passed uh out of our
Collective Consciousness but when I when
we started you know in 2010 or
thereabouts the notion of a snowflake
was a deeply concerning idea to a lot of
people
um and the idea was that you know a lot
of our servers were effectively
snowflakes they were beautiful they were
ornate and they were entirely unique and
if they melted it was impossible to
reconstruct them
right
um and so one of the big campaigns early
on in containers and kubernetes and
orchestration was to say we're getting
rid of your snowflakes
and indeed we have we've gotten rid of
the container Snowflake and if you look
at a kubernetes cluster all of the
images all of the machines within an
Azure kubernetes cluster or Google
kubernetes cluster or anyone's
kubernetes cluster wherever it happens
to be
they're pretty much the same
the trouble is if you take a step back
and you zoom out
we've created snowflake clusters
right so yes okay all the machines look
the same but now we have 20 machines
that are unique from another 20 machines
somewhere else
um and so I think what is really
critical now is that we take and we
realize that maybe the natural state of
the world is the tendency towards
entropy
um and we need to take another crack at
uh at solving the snowflake cluster
problem and indeed
get Ops I think is a really really
powerful way of doing this it's a really
great way of ensuring consistency
because as I mentioned before the flip
from a push model to a pull model means
that get Ops at some level doesn't care
about scale
it doesn't really care how many clusters
you have because within each cluster
you're configured to point to the same
git Repository
and also because if you make the
initialization of that poll Daemon of
the piece of software inside the cluster
that is talking to the uh to the git
repository if you make that part of the
creation of the cluster whether it's the
configuration of a cloud managed
kubernetes cluster or simply the scripts
that you use to instantiate that cluster
wherever it happens to be
it becomes wholly automatic to not just
create a cluster but actually to
initialize it with the right versions of
all of the right software whether it's
intrusion detection monitoring or
anything else you want to sort of land
on that cluster in an initialized state
and then of course keeping it up to date
is equally simple where it's just a PR
just like would depend about earlier
it's a PR to ensure that all the
Clusters in your Fleet have the same
configuration
um and so I think there's a real value
not just in terms of
separation of concerns not just in terms
of empowering our developers but also in
terms of the consistency across the
platform that you can achieve you're not
going to accidentally forget to include
a cluster in the pipeline that happens
to deploy the new version of the
security software you're not going to
have to tell the development team hey
you know we're taking away that region
and we're adding in this new region over
here you'll end up with a consistent
environment however you want to be
now I've talked a lot about get Ops and
a lot about kubernetes I think one of
the more interesting trends that we're
actually seeing is the get Ops is
actually moving beyond just kubernetes
um and in particular we're seeing this
being a pattern that people are applying
to uh public Cloud resources in general
through service operators whether it's
in the cross-plane project or the
service operators that are associated
with all of the different clouds at this
point people are seeing the kubernetes
control plane as a consistent Global
control plane for managing not just
their containerized resources but
actually the instantiations of a
postgres database or a storage a blob
storage system or whatever else you need
to do to have your complete application
because as much as containers are
awesome and kubernetes is a lot of fun
there's a lot of really great services
in artificial intelligence and
everything else that are part of a cloud
that you're going to integrate as part
of your application and we shouldn't
Silo get Ops as being just about
managing the stuff that happens to be in
your kubernetes cluster it can just as
effectively manage the stuff that's in
your cluster as well as the stuff that
happens to be in the cloud
I wanted to close with the last piece of
this which is to say you know I've hyped
this thing for a while
um you might be forgiven for thinking
that like I'm telling you that this is
the only solution
um and in fact it's not actually and I'm
reminded a great deal
um of my time as a uh roboticist I spent
a long time doing Robotics and there was
always this handoff and this interplay
between control and planning
a controller like a thermostat does a
really great job of following a wall you
don't want to use trust me you don't
want to use if else statements to have a
robot that follows along a wall use the
control Loop but a control Loop does a
terrible job of exiting an auditorium
because I have to maneuver I have to say
well I'm going to go here first and then
I'm going to go there and then finally
I'm going to get to my goal controllers
have a tendency to head straight for the
door and then bump into things
and I think this is a useful analogy for
understanding the interplay between
traditional pipeline systems and get Ops
get Ops is effectively a fire and forget
control Loop make this thing into
reality as quickly as you can
that's really fantastic for all of the
reasons that I mentioned before but it's
a terrible way to roll out your software
around the world
if you want to roll your software around
the world you need to move slowly you
want to move to canara you want to move
to a 15 experiment you want to take some
time because if it breaks you don't want
to break everybody
and that's where a planner comes in
place and so really I want to argue that
when we think about pipelines and get
Ops it's not two you know things in
dichotomy it's not a fight but rather
it's too very complementary Technologies
one that is very good at easily making
the state real
and one that is very good at
orchestrating stages of what you want
the world to look like
um and so hopefully that helps you both
understand the value of git Ops in a
container context as well as the
interplay between maybe some traditional
CI systems and the new world of git Ops
thank you so much and see you around